Hello, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're The Slow Mo Guys and in this video,
we will attempt to destroy YouTube's
ability to correctly display it.
Yeah, we're gonna try and annihilate
the compression algorithm.
We've come kind of close
unintentionally before,
with things like the galley of video,
or other videos that have lots of things
going on at the exact
same time on the screen.
It usually happens when
there's tons of fine detail
all over the frame, and
that detail is changing
positions from frame to
frame, like confetti or snow.
And on YouTube, the lower the resolution,
typically the lower the bit rate.
The way we're going to try
and do it is with glitter,
because that's got the
smallest little things,
the finest little detail.
Gonna try and dump as
much of it as we can,
at once on to the camera.
I can't think of a more difficult test
for compression than this.
Hopefully we make a
watchable, unwatchable video.
Yeah hopefully this is the most watchable,
unwatchable video.
Did I just repeat exactly what you said?
Yes.
Okay.
Okay, for these shots, I want the camera
to be looking directly up at the ceiling.
Although on it's head, I can't actually
fully get vertically.
So, I have to finagle this a little bit.
I feel like this tripod is gonna need
a chiropractor after this.
I mean you might as well
give it acupuncture.
They're about the same usefulness.
Oh, hot take be.
It's just flooded instead of spot.
All right, lights flooded,
that's a pretty good
coverage of the ceiling.
All right Dan, this is the
final time that this room
and all of our equipment will
not be covered in glitter.
I'm more nervous than I should be.
Let's take a moment
just to appreciate that.
Look how clean it is.
Look at that.
Everything's not covered in glitter.
I love it.
This is brilliant.
On we go.
Yeah.
Is it getting close?
Yes.
I can't see.
Oh.
All right, quite full.
You ruined it already.
You may remember this device
from our oil fire video.
What?
Just an old video isn't?
Also device is a mug on a stick.
Marcus made it.
Telescopic stick.
Ready?
Yeah.
Oh, goodness me.
There's an audible furn.
It was.
You know what?
I think it's so fine, that
it doesn't like float about.
It just goes boom.
Like I'm pouring liquid onto it.
There's an indication on how small
the little glitter pieces.
Less than a millimeter, easily.
It is less than a millimeter.
I reckon point six-seven,
.7 of a mill.
All right.
Which in American is,
755's of an inch.
Three, two, one, drop.
Oh, that seems better.
That seem much better.
It was much more graceful and
it didn't thud on the glass.
I feel like.
I feel like its, it fell much slower,
because it wasn't one solid mass.
It managed to get some air
underneath it and spread out,
and sort of float down.
Yeah.
Three, two, one, go!
Oh God.
What?
It's like a cloud of fabulous.
It's like when I walk into any room.
Not our most comfortable viewing station.
See there, it's not
filling the whole frame.
I feel like I need to, need to
make the device a bit longer.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Like every, that hurts my eyes.
I like that some are in focus,
and some are totally blurred.
I was trying to do a focus point.
Each glitter piece.
Look at that, there you go.
It looks like a dust cloud, doesn't it?
Ah, I see it caught up
with the focus there.
Yeah, it's like coming towards you.
It looks like a dust storm,
you know when they have like,
the sand storms rolling
across the desert, but red.
Three, two, one, drop.
Dan, did you by any chance
write something in the glitter?
Can you see it?
Well, there's just some gaps.
Yes.
I did write something in the glitter.
I was hoping you wouldn't see it.
What did you write?
The medical term would be penis.
Oh okay.
I can see that you like,
smeared some there.
You can see that it's
smeared right on there.
Yeah.
Look at that.
It's bloody, honestly bloody
hard to pull focus on it,
because there's no like,
unified front either.
There's no leading edge.
This part shot, it's just a mess.
Wow, it looks like red blood cells.
This is what it looks
like to die by glitter.
Yeah, that'd be the end of you.
There's me, there's me
doing my focus point.
Oh yeah.
You're in this video.
Okay, we'll try a blue
and I'm going to zoom in a lot more.
Three, two, one, drop.
Gosh, I'm getting sweaty, which means
that the glitter is
sticking to me, everywhere.
Very full there.
In the frame, oh that's some good.
Wow, that moment there.
Did you see that moment in the end?
It almost looks like convergence
is coming in onto the
center, and when it goes
through, it like spins out.
It looks like spinning, yeah.
Look at it like spinning.
Spinning in a circle.
That's the glitter right
there, those little.
Like, that's really odd.
I really lost focus there,
but that looks cool.
It's really like a phone background.
This might be the most abstract
thing we've ever filmed.
It's crazy.
Do you like it?
I really like it.
There's a bit of red there.
Rogue piece of red.
It didn't move, spot the red.
Yeah.
Wow, that's crazy.
So, I've put more depth in
there, and it's in focus
for a lot longer, which
causes tiny little flares.
It looks like TV static,
but like more detailed.
Yeah, good luck with this
shot, compression wise.
I bet even if I put us
down in the lower corner,
that even our faces will
be just blocky and mush.
Even seeing the raw footage.
I'm not sure if it's coming towards us,
or going away from us.
Yeah.
All right, I think we
get the hang of this now.
Nice zoomed in one, lots
of light, lots of depth.
Think we've done blue?
We have.
So here's what we want.
All five colors,
in a line.
Oh.
Like little strips of each one,
and then maybe after that,
because they'll be mixed together.
We'll just drop a big mixed pile.
Sounds good.
All right.
I'm up for that, okay.
Do you feel like you're on Art Attack?
I do,
love that show.
It was class, wasn't it?
Three, two, one, drop.
Wow.
Bloody hell.
Not dominated by any one particular color.
It almost turned brown though.
Yeah, it was like it was liquid,
because it was mixing so much that
my eyes algorithm messed up.
Perfect bang on center.
Look at that.
Loving it.
It's getting smaller and smaller,
bigger and bigger.
Bigger and bigger.
Look at the green popping.
Green smashing through,
there is the gold and the blue.
Oh, look at that mixture.
What's burning?
I don't know, I smell burning to.
Oh, bloody light is on fire.
It's melting.
Oh God, I can see it smoking.
Ah, it smells wreck.
We might have glitter on the bulb.
Oh.
Oh my goodness, that's worse
than I could have thought.
That's like melted on there.
That has caked it.
Just don't really know how
aggressive to be with this.
All right, lights fixed.
Excellent.
At least for the end of this video.
It has given up smoking.
All right, so now what we can do,
just take all of that
that's all lovely and mixed,
and we'll just drop a plate of that.
Okay, one times plate.
For a grand finale.
You're gonna do a bit of glitter bay?
Oh, yeah sure,
hang on.
Ah it's all over my arm.
Not a good idea.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh.
Oh, look at that.
I estimate three months before
I get all this glitter off.
I'll be finding glitter
in the shower for months.
Not as much bad luck as breaking a mirror,
but it's up there.
It's worse than breaking a mirror,
because breaking a mirror
does actually do nothing.
Well,
coming from the guy with
like 48 years of bad luck.
Look all right,
you don't need to be suspicious to realize
you've got glitter in your
ear from four months ago.
It just happens.
Suspicious?
Superstitious?
Yes.
Three, two, one, drop.
All right, so this one might
be the most mental one.
All the colors mixed together.
Attempting a focus pool.
Goodness me.
That's the big bang.
That is the big bang.
Wow.
It looks like extreme Christmas.
Look at that phone coming through.
Just briefly.
You know how TV displays colors?
Yeah.
This is gonna be hard for a screen
to display colors as well.
Look at that.
Look how many of those.
Each frame is different colors everywhere.
Bit's everywhere.
We should export each individual frame,
and just sell each one as a painting.
Wait, do you have 3794?
Or 3..
Ah.
I get a headache.
Jesus, why is it bleeding?
Oh it's glitter.
Look at the different layers.
I think if we film this in 3D somehow,
my head would split open.
It will explode.
It would explode.
The bit where they're coming
through the flickery mush,
and like coming in,
you can see the little granules.
I want to get a shot that's
pretty much all that.
So, I'm gonna set the focus
to a minimum which is,
well like just under two feet away.
So still go out of focus,
but we should see all
of that flickery mess,
with a little granules
coming through at the front.
Three, two, one.
You see all the little specks inside each?
Yeah.
I see the Iris shape there.
That's because that's the
stuff that's already landed.
Wow.
Oh my God.
Coming through.
That is an amazing effect.
Isn't that cool?
You know what it looks like?
It's when they have those
pictures in the quiz shows,
where it's like, what is this?
And it like, and it
slowly pieces together.
Yeah.
I love the different stages of that one.
That was my favorite one I think.
Wow.
Interestingly on this one,
we left the garage door open,
and you can actually see
the wind is actually,
like subtly affecting it,
it looks like it's stormy.
It's really, it looks like
a maelstrom of glitter.
Yeah, like a few flows and rotations
that we weren't getting on the other ones.
There are honestly so many variations
that we could've tried.
Every single time you do this,
with even the slightest change,
is completely different.
Like on the lens alone,
I can make it look completely different.
Every single one of these is different.
That alone the color of the glitter,
the size of the glitter.
Yeah.
How much has dropped,
how far its dropped.
Oh God.
I forgot, stupid thing.
God sake.
So, do you think we've managed
to defeat YouTube compression?
Oh, I don't know, I feel
like we defeated my eyes.
Defeated my head.
Defeated the monitor.
I feel like even just looking at the raw,
I've never seen such
lossless video like that.
Just all, I'm expecting
compression and I'm not seeing it,
it's so weird.
I was going like cross-eyed
and I shut my eyes,
and seeing the exact same things.
You don't know where to look.
Yeah, yeah.
I truly believe that,
sadly only you and I have truly
been up to see what that
video actually looks like.
Because you wouldn't be able to show it
and compressed like, how
would you show people?
I'd have to,
put it into a,
like a uncompressed quick
time or a stream of tif's.
And shove it on a SSD and just give it
to you in your hands probably.
How many subscribers do we have?
Oh.
Too many.
Although we have been
thrown around the idea
of making a best of Slow Mo Guys,
4K Blu-ray.
So, if that does happen,
that would be the most lossless format
we've ever presented any footage.
That'll be cool.
And I'll definitely stick
that video on there.
So, you'd be more likely to see closer
to what we're seeing in this video.
You could probably get the difference up?
Yeah.
Yeah. You could actually.
You could, because you
couldn't do that on YouTube,
because it would just be like,
they're the same.
Yeah.
We'll do like one of those adverts like,
oh here's The Slow Mo Guys Blu-ray,
here's 1080p HD.
It's like,
It's just a whole mess.
Well, hopefully you enjoyed that video.
You probably didn't, actually.
Even though you got a headache like me.
But we made it anyway,
just to try and break the system.
Thank you very much for watching.
Make sure you subscribe
to The Slow Mo Guys,
and we have a second channel to.
Easier to watch videos on that one.
Yeah.
You've got some glitter on here.
You've got some just, all.
In my eyebrows?
Deep in, within the hair.
Yeah, okay.
Should we clear up?
Ah, lets do it tomorrow.
Yeah.